gregory gusakov and anatoly koniev both
aged 10 tiptoed through the dark deep
woods bordering their quaint russian
village of obrichenye the year was 1990
a turbulent time for the people of
russia seeing as the soviet union was on
the precipice of collapse but for these
two young boys global geopolitics was
the last thing on their minds they were
too busy hunting for the legendary
monstrous witch known only as
baba yega
for those in our audience who grew up in
eastern europe or those at least
decently familiar with slavic folklore
and or the john wick film series mention
of the name baba yeaga likely sends a
slight chill down your spine and if it
doesn't just wait by the end of this
video you'll be afraid to go into the
woods alone not that going with others
would save you as poor little grigori
and anatoly were about to find out the
hard way they forged on through those
witchy woods by our standards the boys
were tough and head strong after all the
russian wilderness could be a brutal
place to grow up and in a town like
obrecheny the old ways of stoicism and
perseverance were prized over fear and
caution all except for one particular
area the supernatural like many small
villages all over the world at every
point in history obrecheny had its fair
share of local superstitions chief among
them was the belief that the local
forest was enchanted and that when
people wandered in among the trees many
of them would never return they would
fall into the gnarled clutches of the
carnivorous witch baba yega and their
bones would lay among the roots and dead
leaves until they someday crumbled into
dust it was starting to get dark out
when the two boys had first set off it
had been with the intention of proving
their medal among the other local
children they didn't fear baba yaga the
old witch in the woods was just another
fairy story meant to frighten children
and they weren't children anymore though
they would never live to be men it
wasn't long before they were beyond the
point of no return which way was out and
which way was further in it hardly
mattered anymore as carry-on birds
caught far above the bravado that put
them here was starting to falter now but
neither dared show it they'd rather be
put in mortal peril than show fear in
front of one another was something
moving in the distant shadows a thin
twisted human figure impossible to make
out save for the faint glow of its eyes
in the gathering dark they couldn't tell
what was real and what was their mind
playing cruel tricks on them a horse
whisper issued through the brittle trees
in the moments that followed it was an
ancient voice a voice that had echoed in
the nightmares of generations a voice
that had seen centuries it spoke in an
older russian dialect that neither of
the young boys could understand but
somehow the essence of its message still
run clear in their hearts and minds
welcome little children
to my forest
here your lives are forfeited
you
are my property
i look forward to chewing the tender
meat
of your young bones
that was all they needed to hear to
start running gregorian anatoly turned
and fled screaming for help into the
darkness of the forest both gasped as
they ran through what seemed to be a
giant spider web they spat and
spluttered trying to swat away the silky
strands as they ran from the voice
little did they know what they'd just
run through was no spider web they tried
to press on but their footsteps slowed
the forest was changing around them
twisting shifting
sparkling what had seemed terrifying
before was suddenly
oddly
beautiful
the two boys just stood and watched as
the forest turned into a gorgeous
technicolor light show unlike anything
they'd ever seen before strange figures
hopped and danced through the foliage
one tall figure approached them out of
the trees a beautiful fair-haired maiden
the two boys were entranced by her their
hearts filled with pure golden light why
were they running before they couldn't
even remember they just smiled as the
woman approached them in her long
flowing dress smiling back she was like
something out of a fairy tale they
didn't react they didn't even realize
what was happening as the jaws of the
horrible ancient old crone closed around
their skulls for the last time gregorian
anatoly were never seen again
just another two children gone missing
in the woods the latest entries on a
long list of tragedies to hit the
village of obrecheny but they were also
the straws that broke the camel's back
the villagers were sick of living in
fear under the fabled witch they would
have their revenge the men of the
village gathered up their weapons and
formed a hunting party guns torches
knives axes and fury they would slay the
beast that had taken so many of their
friends and their children in the woods
as soon as their forces were assembled
they charged into the forest looking for
blood with their numerical advantage and
single-minded determination it didn't
take them long to find the monster in
the woods she was every bit as hideous
and nightmarish as they had anticipated
a gnarled snarling crone with long
clawed fingers and dirty fangs they got
her in their sights and prepared to open
fire but none of them were ready for
baba yega's counter-offensive
she moved like a leaf in a strong wind
swift and effortless the men who'd made
the mistake of getting too close to her
with knives and axes tasted her terrible
wrath she tore through them with claws
like iron sank her fangs into their
flesh lifted and tossed them like
ragdolls how could she be so fast and so
strong the men were terrified this was
no mere woman it was a true monster
squeezed into a barely human form by the
time the creature was finally
incapacitated he'd taken countless
bullets and strikes how any creature
could survive such an assault was
unimaginable several members of the
hunting party were dead by this point
others had been overtaken by a strange
form of madness a couple of them had
been given to constant giggling fits or
were speaking long strings of nonsense
others had been rendered entirely
catatonic by the experience it was clear
that the witch had powers beyond their
understanding they needed to return it
to the village and destroy it as quickly
as possible the monster was bound and
dragged back to obrechenyi after seeing
how it bewitched some of the men they
avoided direct contact whenever possible
they would do everything they could to
see justice done of course there would
be no due process for baba yega the
violence that had erupted in the forest
was more than enough proof to justify
the beast's immediate death sentence the
local priest gave a prayer though he
remarked that he was sure this monster
was the creation and servant of the
devil and the execution commenced a
local used a blessed sword anointed with
holy water to hack off the baba yega's
head its body was shot several times for
good measure and it was finally doused
in gasoline and set on fire the remains
were buried just outside the village
limits hoping that the baba yega's evil
wouldn't continue to haunt their town
even in death isolated villages in the
russian step aren't famous for their
communication with outsiders especially
back in 1990 when the soviet union was
still clinging on to control and the
internet was still in its infancy it
took a few weeks for news of a village
capturing a so-called local witch to
reach the scp foundation after closely
studying the peculiar disappearance
records in the area they sent over a
detachment of field agents to
investigate and perhaps conduct a few
interviews with the locals they had no
way of knowing there wouldn't be any
left by the time they arrived when the
field agents reached oberchenyi it was
already a ghost town not a single
survivor was found only the evidence of
fresh carnage desiccated bodies were
found in some of the village's houses
and others only body parts a hole in the
ground next to the village seemed to
show evidence of some subterranean
creature clawing its way back up to the
top whatever this creature was it
clearly crawled back up from the earth
and exacted bloody revenge against those
who had buried it blood trails from some
of the bodies leading back into the
woods made it clear where the creature
had fled to after massacring the entire
village given the sudden increase in the
situation's severity mobile task force
epsilon vi aka the village idiots were
brought in to apprehend the fugitive
witch but much like the literal village
idiots that had come before them this
mtf had no idea what they were up
against they entered the forest outside
obracenni with superior tactics and
weaponry to the villagers with orders to
contain the creature at all costs they
didn't exactly know what they were
searching for in the dark amongst the
trees but when the first operatives laid
eyes on the twisted old crone they
almost reflexively relaxed their guard
for some of the village idiots this
would be the last mistake they ever made
some of the operatives began to feel
funny much like grigori anatoly and some
members of the hunting party they began
to see the forest warping and shifting
around them they giggled at all the
funny colors inside feeling an
overwhelming sense of calmness and
euphoria it was honestly the best they'd
felt in years perhaps they were wrong
about hunting the witch in here maybe
the real anomaly here was a russian
force that made you feel awesome when
you stepped inside while the affected
agents were giggling away in their own
little la la land baba yega was bringing
the pain with the same freakish speed
strength and ferocity that had surprised
the hunting party weeks earlier the
witch was tearing through mtf epsilon vi
ripping through hardened tactical armor
with her long claws and teeth she took
shot after shot enough tranquilizer to
put down an elephant but she kept
fighting in the end the training and
numerical superiority of the task force
won out they were able to secure and
contain the baba yeaga soon redesignated
scp-352 and take it to a nearby
foundation containment site for further
studies there they officially recorded
all the details from the creature's
incredible speed and strength to its
regenerative ability so extensive that
it could even survive being decapitated
and burned but what about the
hallucinogenic effects like a hungry
spider the baba yega's true power comes
in her ability to spin a deadly web her
body is able to produce long thin
hair-like fibers each one coated in
powerful hallucinogenic enzymes that
induce a sense of placid euphoric
stillness in its victims when it isn't
engaging multiple targets the creature
can sometimes take multiple days to
consume a single still living victim
taking them apart and eating them piece
by piece
speaking of eating as you can probably
imagine in order to keep scp-352
uneventfully contained it's ideal to
make sure it isn't hangry in order to
keep 352 well-fed they need to stock up
on its favorite food human flesh though
specifically 352 has a real hankering
for babies while the foundation are
currently exploring anomalous means of
keeping the baba yega fed until those
means are fully ironed out they need to
keep this monster fed the old-fashioned
way only ever withdrawing food as
punishment if it attempts to breach
containment after all there's a very
good reason why parents and children
across the slavic world fear baba yega
she's always hungry and in the end she
always gets what she wants now go check
out
scp-3999 i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me and waldo finds you
scp-4885 find him for more of the most
frightening anomalies out there